[MUSIC PLAYING]
JJ BEHRENS: Hi, I'm JJ.
And here we have our
next episode of
YouTube Developers Live.
We have Jarek Wilkiewicz
down at the end.
And we have two guests today,
Kevin and Matt from Kamcord.
And later on, we're going to
be talking with Jeffrey
Posnick and Vladimir Vuskovic,
who is PM for YouTube APIs.
So we got a really
full show today.
Jarek, I remember at Google I/O,
we had one talk on gaming
where we had Dude Perfect and
the guy who created Tony Hawk
3 and everyone else.
And so I'm guessing that the
goal today is to see how many
people we could fit
on the stage?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes,
JJ, precisely.
We are trying to hit the limit
of how many people we can fit
in the studio.
We actually have a live
audience today.
So this is a shout out for
people in the room that are
actually helping us keep
this energized.
But the real purpose for today's
live episode of our
YouTube Developers Live is to
show you an exciting piece of
technology that is being
developed by a
company called Kamcord.
And it really goes in line with
one of the approaches
that we discussed at Google I/O
to solving the problems
related to mobile
video capture.
So Kamcord uses one of the
approaches that involves local
video capture and coding.
And they've been quite
successful at that.
I'm personally very excited
about this approach and this
technology.
So I can't wait to ask a
bunch of questions and
then see a live demo.
Since, of course, this is a
show for developers so it
wouldn't be valid
without a demo.
So I hope the demo's going
to work, right?
KEVIN WANG: Of course.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
so let's get into it.
We have Kevin and Matt
here, so maybe I'll
start with you, Matt.
So tell me a little
bit about Kamcord.
What prompted you to
start the company?
Why mobile?
And how did you guys actually
arrive at the idea?
How long have you been at it?
Just give me a little
background
about you guys first.
And then we'll drill into some
of the technical details.
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah,
sounds great.
So Kamcord is a mobile
recording
technology for games.
And the reason we built
the technology is
that we are all gamers.
We have three co-founders.
And basically, we were on our
mobile phones a lot and
playing these games.
And we had these really awesome
moments, but we
weren't able to share them with
our friends, our family,
and others online.
And we really felt that Kamcord
was a great way to
capture a video of this content
on the phone or tablet
and then be able to share that
on YouTube and other social
medium channels.
And then what happened is we
started reaching out to some
of our friends that build mobile
games and realized that
game developers really have a
distribution problem today.
They have to try to somehow
get on the charts.
And the problem there is
that that can be very
expensive for them.
And we wanted to really create
a way that allows a user to
kind of promote that game on
behalf of the game developer.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So I heard you used to
work for Google.
Did you have time to play games
back when you were at
Google or is this--
you quit to play games?
What's the story there?
MATT ZITZMANN: I personally
have always played games.
I had three siblings that went
to University of Michigan.
And we lived about an hour
and a half away.
And I was about eight
years old.
And we had a little 9-inch inch
TV that we would put in
our minivan.
And I would play Madden
Football and all these
different games while we were
driving to the university.
And I just always
played games.
My dad was a real estate
developer.
And we would play Sim
City together.
So gaming has been
a part of my life
from really the get-go.
And mobile--
basically what happened is I
personally became busier and
busier in life and just didn't
have time to spend three hours
playing a game.
And when I was at Google, I
would jump on the shuttle.
And I would have a few minutes
here or there before I was
going to do email.
And mobile gaming lends itself
very well for that type of
experience where you only have
three or five minutes while
waiting in line for
lunch, et cetera.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So tell me--
say I'm a game developer and
I'm developing a game
using Nginx.
What are my choices here?
Is there a technology that will
allow me to address all
the platforms?
What's the state of the art
from your perspective?
How does your solution fit
into the overall puzzle?
MATT ZITZMANN: Right.
So when we started with this
idea, we started looking
around and trying to figure
out who else had addressed
this problem of unlocking the
content from the device.
And we really didn't find
another company that was
creating a solution.
And we found other solutions.
But they were kind of a no-go
for the game developer to put
in their actual game, primarily
because it would
slow down the gameplay.
And so from day one when Kevin
started building the
prototype, it was really a
matter of thinking about how
can we build this technology
in a way that does not slow
down the gameplay.
Because the user still wants to
have a game that runs at 60
fps and really can enjoy
the game as they have
always played it.
But Kamcord can now sit in the
background basically recording
and allowing and kind of
seamlessly, passively
recording the screens.
The user doesn't really need
to think about starting and
stopping, recording.
It's just working behind
the scenes for them.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So how about you give
us a little demo?
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah, sure.
So we're going to have our third
co-founder, Adi, give us
a demo here.
Give this one moment
to transition.
All right.
So we have a game here
called Lost Robot.
This game is currently in the
app store approval process, so
it will be going live soon.
[GAME MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT ZITZMANN: And basically
what you have to do is you
have to help this robot
get back home.
And so what Adi's doing here is
moving these little gates
out of the way.
And behind the scenes,
what's going on is
Kamcord is just recording.
You as a user don't really need
to think about anything.
And so this was just a
really basic level.
We just figured we'd keep it
really simple for this demo.
And in the top left
there is a button.
And if you press that button,
you'll be taken
to the Kamcord screen.
And then on this Kamcord screen,
we have a replay
button so you can see exactly
what you just did.
I hope everyone's enjoying
the elevator music.
I guess it's a little more
hip than elevator music.
All right, so that's the
end of the level again.
So that's a replay of
what you just did.
And then we have these
different--
obviously--
sharing functionalities.
So if you click the YouTube
button, that will take you to
the YouTube screen where
you can share.
And then the user can
type in a message.
And hit Share.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
That's really neat.
So it looks like it's very
well integrated into the
overall experience.
So Kevin, tell me a little bit
about what's involved on the
technical side.
If I want to integrate this into
my game, do I have to use
a specific game engine?
How about the YouTube
uploading?
What APIs do you guys use?
How about the user
authentication?
Give us some background about
all the pieces of the stack,
how they fit together.
KEVIN WANG: Right.
So we have basically one
SDK, one framework for
iOS per game engine.
So if you use a particular game
engine, you'll download
that framework, include it
in your code, basically.
And the API that we offer
is pretty simple.
It's basically just start and
stop recording because we just
want to make the APIs as
simple as possible for
developers.
And basically once you start
and after you stop, if you
want your own UI to show the
video, or you can use the one
that we showed that comes
with our software.
So that's basically like if you
want to get more than half
the value, you could just
do that with just a
couple lines of code.
You'll get pretty far.
In terms of the authentication
with YouTube, we use GData.
So we just use the standard
libraries.
And you didn't see in that demo,
but we'd already logged
into our account before.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Are you guys
using the GTM OAuth 2
controller?
KEVIN WANG: Yes, we are.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Cool.
Good answers.
Because when people say, I'm
using ClientLogin on this
show, we normally
kick them out.
Great.
And then are there
any limitations?
Like you mentioned that you're
trying to implement the
solution such that there's very
little overhead and the
frame rate is not affected.
And what's the catch?
Is there a limited buffer size
that you can actually capture
the gameplay video?
How do you guys--
what other things that
are limiting?
KEVIN WANG: Right.
So it's pretty neat.
So for example, on your iOS
phone, like the native camera
app, that will write all your
video as it's being recorded
live to the device disk.
And that way uses just a
constant amount of RAM, so you
can record for as long
as you want.
And we used that same
tech, basically.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Cool.
And right now, you mentioned
there's one
engine supported today?
KEVIN WANG: Yes, that
engine is cocos2d.
We're planning to expand
to more in the future.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Any plans to look into
Android as well?
Since we're at Google?
KEVIN WANG: Yeah, that's
definitely the plan.
Absolutely, absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Really cool.
So how do people get
started with this?
Like if I'm building a cocos2d
game, where do I go?
What do I need to sign?
What's the process?
KEVIN WANG: If you go to our
site on kamcord.com--
K-A-M-C-O-R-D dot com--
you can basically sign up
for the developer key.
And after that, you can download
the SDK documentation
and get started right away.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Great.
Now, JJ here, he's a very
famous mobile gamer.
So when will he be able to share
his achievements with
some of the apps that
are coming?
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah.
We have 13 games live on the
app store today, and we'll
have about 25 live by
the end of August.
And we hope to have 100 by
the end of the year.
And just continue to grow the
company into more and more
games, more game engines,
Android, et cetera.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Couple
of other questions.
Anything that surprised
you while you
were developing solution?
Like things that you were just
not expecting that totally
blew your mind?
Like this question,
for example.
KEVIN WANG: I think one thing
that was sort of funny was as
you're building a product in the
early days, you have your
core competency, which is making
this recording very
fast and seamless.
And we're trying to think of
adding more features, et
cetera, to the product.
And those take time and it could
be a little bit buggy.
And what was really surprising
for us was that as we were
talking to our developers who
were basically trying to use
our software, what they told
us was the core of what you
have is golden.
And they were willing to work
with us to fix all the
problems that they
came across.
When you're starting a company,
you always try to
write software very fast.
Things always break.
And we expected people
to get upset or
frustrated as things--
we roll out a new feature, it
works part of the time.
The other time it breaks.
Right?
Everyone's just been--
they just come back and ask you,
oh, yeah, here's a bug,
here's a log report
if you fix this.
And when we do, they're
really happy.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sounds like
a great community to work
with-- people actually
supporting your effort--
MATT ZITZMANN: It really is.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --as opposed
to treating you as somebody
who's trying to sell
them something.
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah.
Just to add to that, I think
probably the number one thing
that came to my mind when you
asked the question was our
interactions with the developers
has just been
unbelievable.
We had one guy that was at the
hospital when his wife was
giving birth.
We've had two brothers
that quit their jobs.
And they're down in Guatemala
designing this awesome game
that's going to be coming
out very, very soon.
We've interacted with hundreds
of developers now.
And they all have a different
story, a different motivation
for building games, whether
it just be for fun
or financial gain.
And just getting to know these
guys and their personalities
has just been pretty cool.
KEVIN WANG: Yeah, there have
been a couple times where it's
late on a Friday night.
And we're about to finish.
And we get an email-- hey,
Kevin, this is broken--
these guys from down
in Guatemala.
So we stayed up and worked till
7:00 AM just trying to
fix the bugs.
They're trying to release, so
we got to support them.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Anything that
surprised you with the
YouTube API?
Like any areas where you
felt like we fell flat,
or we could do better?
Any tricky things, pieces of
advice for future generations
of YouTube API developers?
Things that you think are tricky
and need some better
explanation?
KEVIN WANG: So the way we did
it, mostly I just went to the
sample code, copied and pasted
as much as I could.
And that actually worked.
It got me immediately 90% of
the way there, I would say.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool, cool.
KEVIN WANG: It was a little
bit hard to find some
documentation, I found.
So it was mostly just
trial and error.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You think
our search engine
is not doing good?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KEVIN WANG: It got me to the
right page, inside the page.
JJ BEHRENS: Wait a second,
which search
engine were you using?
KEVIN WANG: It starts
with a Y.
JJ BEHRENS: That could
be the problem.
MATT ZITZMANN: I would say one
thing more at the product
level is having--
gaming today, we can do either
recordings or live streaming.
And I think live streaming could
be a really interesting
proposition in the future.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Directly
from the mobile game?
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah.
And we have a lot of crazy ideas
about where we want to
take Kamcord in the future.
But yeah, being able
to basically--
I imagine or envision a world
where a group of friends could
go back home after school.
And one of the guys is playing
his game on his tablet, and
all his friends could be in that
room with him watching.
And it's just like a place for
them to hang out after school.
And I think that could be a
really powerful thing to have
a synchronous connection.
Now, that said, mobile and
tablets lend themselves more
to the asynchronous
experience.
But I think having the
opportunity to experiment with
those unique, new types of
entertainment experiences
would be really interesting
to us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You think
you're going to have that
working by the next
Google I/O?
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah, we'll
definitely have it working.
That's a year away.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm going
to take you up on that.
JJ BEHRENS: I know we have a
lot of developers watching.
And I just wonder if you guys
had any words of wisdoms for
developers out there.
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah, I think
for us, we try to be super
hands on when people
have issues.
And so providing us as many
details as possible--
[? stack ?] traces and just
describing your problems,
screenshots, even send
us a little bit
of your source code.
Calling us, Skyping, all of
these different things.
Just basically trying to provide
us as much information
so that we can help solve
the problems that
you're running into.
KEVIN WANG: Yeah, I would say
we talk a lot to developers
through email and a little
bit through Skype.
Skype is always the best and
we're really always happy to
jump on a call.
And for email, if you just tell
us what the problem is,
and what you need, even.
Don't be afraid to ask
us, tell us, this is
what we need to launch.
That makes our jobs easier,
actually, if you tell us your
exact specs.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Yeah, the bug reports I normally
get, it just say, it
doesn't work.
MATT ZITZMANN: Yeah, we get a
lot of that and then you go
back and we end up getting
to where we need to be.
But if we can short-circuit
there to that end state, it
helps a ton.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Well, thank you very much for
giving us an intro to the
technology and answering all
the tough questions.
We have a lot of content to
cover in this hour, so I'm
going to hand it over to JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Yep, and now we're
going to talk to Vladimir
Vuskovic, product manager
for YouTube APIs.
And Vladimir, first of all,
where are you and
what time is it?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah,
I'm in Zurich.
It is 7:20 in the evening.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
Thanks for staying up and
chatting with us.
So whatcha working--
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Actually,
it is the 1st of August, so
it's Swiss national
holiday today.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, is it?
Well, I mean, it's Europe.
That's like--
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: So
everybody's partying.
JJ BEHRENS: I mean, it's
Europe, though.
There's a holiday every other
day, as far as I could tell.
So Vladimir, what are
you working on?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: So currently,
we are really,
really busy.
We are working on a
bunch of things.
First thing on our mind is the
new version of the YouTube
API, the version 3.
And so we are really busy trying
to launch it publicly
as soon as possible.
In addition to that, we are
working on a bunch of
interesting things like exposing
more of the partner
features through the API.
Exposing the analytics
data through the API.
We are working on also exposing
some of the newest
YouTube features through
the API.
So we are really, really
busy in this period.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So a lot of people--
aside from the people
watching this show--
when they think of YouTube,
they don't
necessarily think of APIs.
And yet Jarek and I see a lot
of crazy apps built with the
YouTube APIs.
Can you tell me some of your
favorite apps that you've seen
built with YouTube APIs?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Oh, yeah,
that's a good question.
So yeah, the applications using
the YouTube APIs are the
[? vastest ?]
possible span.
So from websites to mobile
apps like a little
[? clipboard ?]
to games, game consoles
like PlayStation.
So it's really hard to pick.
Perhaps the ones that's most
interesting to me is like it's
[INAUDIBLE]
the rowboats like
the air drones.
They are using the API to upload
the videos they record
while flying and later upload
to YouTube, so they have a
really cool channel, as well.
So this is something really,
really cool.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: It's perhaps
my favorite one
[INAUDIBLE]
of the strange ones.
JJ BEHRENS: I like the
air drone, too.
So if you look at YouTube,
there's a lot of features on
the site that aren't actually
present in the API.
Why is that?
And how do you make the decision
as to what goes into
the API and what's only
for the website?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
So the lag between the features
being on YouTube and
being exposed to the API, it's
mostly because on YouTube, we
launch stuff really, really fast
and need to write on it.
And so we need some time to
stabilize the interface until
we can decide to give it out
to the API is one thing.
The other thing is resources.
So the API team needs
to keep up with all
the development space.
And we are getting quite
better at that.
So one of the reasons that we
are launching v3 is because
it's going to enable us to
shorten this period and to be
quicker to catch up
on the API side.
So this is something that we are
working on hard to reduce
this lag as much as we can.
Also, one of the things that you
can expect coming out soon
that are available on the site
and not in the API, for
instance, are topics.
So we are working hard
to expose the
topics through the API.
And I expect that to be
out relatively soon.
I cannot comment on a date,
but it's a matter
of a month or two.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I know that
I've gone to, for instance,
the Player team's meeting.
And those guys move so
incredibly quickly you never
know what they're
going to add.
And yet, on the API team, we
have this amazing deprecation
policy where we try really,
really hard not to break apps.
So does that have an impact on
what you include in the API
and how hesitant you are?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Absolutely,
absolutely.
So we tend to include in the
APIs things that we think
reach the certain level of
maturity so that they're going
to stay for a while.
It's not mandatory because we
can always expose that through
the API and have an experimental
API until we
establish the interface.
But in general, you are right.
So this is one of the reasons
that the API lags a bit.
But yeah, I said before this
is going to improve.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
So when I think of product
managers, I always have this
exalted vision of them where
there's this massive boat.
And they're steering the boat,
and they're trying not to run
into things.
And they have this vision of
where they're going to go in
the future.
One question is mobile's
really big.
How is mobile impacting
your vision of the
future right now?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah, mobile
is key, for sure.
So the consumption of videos
on mobile, and everything
around mobile is just growing
incredibly [? vastly. ?]
So we absolutely put mobile in
the center of our strategy.
So one example for that is the
recently launched [INAUDIBLE]
[? boundary ?] player API.
I don't know if you guys seen
that, but that's something
that we really pushed forward.
And we think that this will
enable a whole new generation
of apps and really fuel
innovation in the ecosystem
around videos.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So not everyone is a content
partner, but a few of the
people in our audience
are content partners.
And sometimes they've talked
to me about the fact that
there are some things that you
could do via our content
management system that you can't
do via the YouTube API.
Are we going to be able to give
them an API to do some of
those things in the future?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: OK, so
until now, the only way
partners could interact
programmatically with YouTube
was through what we
call ingestion.
So through XML feeds that they
would need to submit
over SFTP to us.
And then we would process those
feeds and interact with
the content management system.
And so now we are trying to
make this a bit better.
So we are working hard on
launching the partner API that
are going to be very much
similar and bound to the v3
YouTube API.
And that will enable exactly
that kind of interaction as
you mentioned before.
So basically interacting with
the CMS and doing the same
kind of things that you
are able to do today
using the CMS UI--
the Content Management
System UI-- or these
ingestion XML feeds.
So we are in the trusted
testers phase now.
And we are testing the first
alpha version of
those partner APIs.
And we are really excited that
this is going quite well.
So this is also something
that we expect to
launch relatively soon.
In addition to that, we are
also working on our other
partner features like the
branding API we just launched
recently to allow partners to
brand the channels through the
API or the analytics API to get
your analytics from the
API and analyze them yourself.
So yes, so there is a lot of
effort around exposing more
information to partners
through the API.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
Now, I know, looking at the
roadmap every quarter, I'm
always amazed at how many things
the YouTube API team is
working on.
I just can't imagine how you
could not get pulled in every
direction at the same time.
What are the things that you
guys are working on that
you're most excited about?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah,
it's really hard one.
So I'm really excited
about the v3.
Really, really excited, so I'm
looking forward to that.
Another thing that we recently
launched that I'm really
excited about is the YouTube
Upload Widget.
So that's something that
I really like a lot.
So it basically enables
developers to put [INAUDIBLE]
IFrame--
a piece of YouTube--
on their site and then enable
their users to upload videos
either to webcam or by selecting
files to YouTube
directly from their website
without leaving it.
And along with it, we offer a
set of JavaScript API to have
better control of [? recent ?]
events and things like this.
So I was really excited
about that launch.
That happened recently.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I'm going
to have to agree with you.
The webcam widget's probably
my favorite new API.
So I agree.
That's really exciting.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I have
one question for Vlad.
Hey, Vlad.
So I am told that you have
PhD in robotics.
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah,
that's true.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the
question is how does one with
PhD in robotics become a YouTube
product manager?
And do you have any pieces of
advice for people that would
like to become product managers
at YouTube, at Google?
What type of career trajectory
they should pursue to become
product manager?
JJ BEHRENS: Aside from getting
a PhD in robotics
and moving to Zurich?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well,
if that's the
advice, then so be it.
But I'm just curious
to see how that
fits into your thinking.
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah, I think
there are several paths
to become a project
manager at Google.
So you can have entrepreneurial
experience,
for instance.
Or you can just be fresh out of
university with good grades
and join the APM program
in Google.
This is a very interesting
path for new
graduates or new PhDs.
So I followed a different
path.
After the PhD, I was
working for a
startup doing Java compilers.
So it just happened.
But gather as much experience as
you can in several fields,
possibly, so that you
can prove that you
have an open mindset.
I think it's really important.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
Do you have any more words of
wisdom before we wrap up?
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah, we can
perhaps just mention the
new v3 and some timelines around
when we plan to launch
it, so I think we--
JJ BEHRENS: I was afraid
to ask you.
But then, of course, everyone
wants to know that question.
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Yeah,
I know, I know.
Everybody's asking
that one, yeah.
So we are really working hard
and we think that we're going
to be able to launch in the next
couple of months maximum.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
That'll be a nice day when--
there will be client libraries
that will--
one client library
to rule them all.
Per language, of course.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I
call that nirvana.
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Another thing
that I just wanted to
mention quickly is I just want
to apologize to those who
applied to join the
testing phase and
haven't been selected.
Because currently, the API's
changing on a daily basis, so
it's not stable enough to have
a broad base of testers.
But yeah, I said before.
So the good news is we are
launching soon the beta
version 2 to everybody.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow.
Thanks a lot, Vladimir.
Thanks for coming in
on your holiday.
We really appreciate it.
Next up, we have Jeffrey
Posnick, developer programs
engineer for YouTube APIs.
Everyone knows Jeffrey.
Jeffrey, you have some special
words of wisdom for us today
or something like that.
What are you going to talk
to us about today?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, I think
something like that probably
is a good catch-all
for what I wanted
to share with everybody.
I guess I wanted to give a
little bit of an update on
what's been happening in the
community in the past week.
And one thing of note is a blog
post that Jarek made that
went up this past Friday.
And this is a blog
post that is--
I don't know-- two years
in the making, maybe.
We had a very, very long beta
period for the IFrame YouTube
player and the associated
API--
well, I guess the associated
API, in particular.
And we are now officially
out of beta.
This is something that
people ask about--
not on a daily basis in the
Google Groups and whatnot.
But we definitely get nervous
developers who have seen the
beta tag attached to the IFrame
player API in the past
and said, hey, does this mean I
really shouldn't be using it
in my apps?
I really don't want to publish
something that might change at
any time, that sort of thing.
So that's all understood.
And we had a few internal things
we had to take care of
before we could remove
that beta label.
One of the things is alluded
to in the blog post.
And that was basically changing
the names of some of
the interfaces to the API.
So if you pull up the post on
our apiblog.youtube.com, feel
free to go and read it
after watching this.
You'll just basically note that
we changed the name of
one of the callback functions.
And we actually changed the URL
that you use to pull in
the JavaScript for
the player API.
The reason we did that was to
actually unify that API with
the Upload Widget API
that Vlad was
talking about earlier.
So there's now actually only one
JavaScript file that you
need to pull in.
And regardless of whether you're
using the IFrame Player
API and the Upload Widget or
you're just using one or the
other, or if you're using
both, you just have
to pull in one file.
And you have one callback
function when it's loaded.
So now that we've made that
change, we feel pretty
confident that we're ready to
make the IFrame Player API a
fully supported API, subject
to our normal deprecation
policy, everything like that.
And if you've been holding off
on using it in any of your
apps, please don't be nervous
about it anymore.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
That's really good news.
I know a lot--
JEFFREY POSNICK:
And you know--
sorry, just one more thing.
And because it's not beta, that
does not mean that we
have yet achieved 100% feature
parity with, let's say, the
JavaScript Player API.
And it doesn't mean that there
will not occasionally be bugs
because supported production
products do have bugs every
once in a while.
But we're going to continue to
take all the feedback that we
get from the developer
community about new
functionality and/or bugs
and address that as
promptly as we can.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
I know that the IFrame
API's been stable for
a pretty long time.
But I know that some people
were worried about it just
because of the beta status.
So this is good news.
And I really like that
API, so that's great.
So I'm looking at Moderator and
it doesn't look like we
have any questions.
That must mean that Jeffrey
actually answered
them before the talk.
It actually is more
effective--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: There is
actually an entry there.
And I'm not sure if this is
a comment or a question--
someone from Laos.
New for me.
So the way I think about this is
they haven't actually seen
this show before.
Where they can find more
information, how can they keep
up to date on what's happening
in the YouTube API?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, well,
we have two guests.
How did you guys learn about
the YouTube API?
KEVIN WANG: We used your
search engine.
JJ BEHRENS: You googled
for YouTube API?
Yeah, that's pretty effective,
actually.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But one
comment is this show is live
every Wednesday at 10:00
AM Pacific time.
If you go to
developers.google.com/live,
you will actually see
the schedule.
There's many other interesting
broadcasts, as well.
And you can catch the
past episodes of
our Hangout on YouTube.
So if you go to the Google
Developers channel, search for
YouTube there, you will find all
the past events that you
have missed.
So you can catch up
pretty quickly.
It'll only take a few hours.
We've been doing this
for about a quarter.
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then
you're welcome to join us
every Wednesday from now on.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
OK, thank you guys
for coming in.
Thank you, Vladimir--
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sorry.
JJ BEHRENS: Go ahead.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Just to
interrupt you for a second.
To make our manager happy
because she definitely had
asked us to do this, and to make
me happy because we're
always looking for
more teammates.
Basically, the YouTube developer
relations team is
looking to hire some
new folks.
And we wanted to encourage
people who are watching to
visit developers.google.com/jobs
if
you're interested in doing the
same sort of thing that Jarek,
JJ, and I do.
JJ BEHRENS: And we also
have a special guest.
He's not miked up.
But he's going to try to
sneak in behind us
and peek in the camera.
This is Jeremy, our
new developer
advocate for YouTube APIs.
And he's going to be helping out
Jarek and I. So the team
is growing.
And we are answering
more questions.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Welcome.
JJ BEHRENS: Jeremy, welcome
to the team.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Official
welcome to the team.
JJ BEHRENS: Handsome guy.
And I think that's it.
Thank you guys for
joining, Vladimir
and Jeffrey and Kamcord.
Thanks a lot.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Bye, guys.
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]